(whooshing)
- I love that message about not starting
the day with email and starting
at 10:30 or 11 o'clock,
what then do you recommend that
entrepreneurs do start their day with?
- Well, I'll give you
a very simple process.
I was teaching this to
someone in Japan yesterday.
Actually, a very large number
of people in Japan yesterday.
And it starts with a
piece of paper and you.
A piece of paper and a
pen, will make you rich.
We won't go into goal setting,
it's a whole separate process.
But make a list of everything
you have to do tomorrow.
The best time to make your
lists is the night before.
If you make a list of your
whole day for tomorrow,
your subconscious will
work on your list overnight
and you'll wake up in
the morning with ideas
and insights that are
sometimes quite amazing.
So you make a list, and
then you look at the list,
and you ask this simple question.
If I could only do one thing on this list
before I was called out
of town for a month,
which one task would I want
to be sure to get completed,
and put a circle around that.
Now, when you get up in the morning,
whatever time you start,
and that's a very interesting point.
Wealthy people get up
in the morning by 6 am.
Poor people get up at 7 or afterwords.
Wealthy people get up earlier,
poor people get up later, real simple.
So if you're getting up around 7 o'clock,
you're always going to be poor,
for the simple reason by
the time you get started
the day's half finished, and
now you're checking your email
and you're talking to your friends,
and then it's lunch time, and coffee time,
and span time, and everything else.
Get up at 6 o'clock and develop a ritual.
Get up, exercise, then sit, plan your day,
get organized, and start
to hit it at 8 o'clock.
And the first thing you do is you
start on your most important task,
and then you concentrate
single mindedly on that task.
You do not turn on your email.
You do not turn on your telephone.
You don't do anything
except that one task,
and you just do this one
task until it's completed.
Now, you've already agreed
with yourself and the world
that there is nothing
more valuable in the world
that you could do than this one task.
So do this, and if you develop a habit
of getting up in the morning,
and starting and completing
your most important task,
it will transform your life.
It's one of the most incredible
productivity habits ever discovered.
And every person who discovers it,
they see their income, their productivity,
their performance, and their
satisfaction just explode.
It's very simple.
The question is do you
have the discipline,
do you have the self control,
the will power to start and complete
your most important task?
If you don't have it, you
can develop it with practice.
If you develop with practice,
it soon becomes easy and automatic.
And if you just do this,
your productivity will
double the first day.
(whooshing)